around uh 2017 2018 and uh kind of
leading up to that time period uh was
the block size wars and i think this is
one of those things where the further we
get away from it uh there's fewer and
fewer people in the crypto industry all
these new people they don't really
understand what that was or kind of what
the different uh perspectives were walk
us through kind of your recollection of
uh that time and then kind of the
decisions that you all made uh in terms
of um you know what eventually became
bitcoin cash and all that yeah at that
time i think um
uh it was kind of driving by kind of a
passion uh you know um the bitcoin
changed my whole life right from
kind of a poor student
and
later uh become kind of a so-called
beginning or something uh and um
it's also kind of a boost of my
confidence right i can do things i can
make things happen
uh so
i have to say because of the whole
journey
you
have kind of a very strong attachment
towards bitcoin i i think i believe a
lot of the audience here even increasing
upon may have the same kind of
feelings that bitcoin is something that
changes the life of you guys and you
just feel quite passionate about it you
want to do great things about it um and
we all know that the scanning debate was
very important at that time um and the
two different uh two different group of
peoples have different ideas uh about
what is the best uh for the bitcoin um i
think
bitcoin uh
was able to uh enjoying quite a good
life uh very good golden times happy
times uh before the skating was unusual
because uh satoshi nakamoto coded a
one megabyte had a
limit there
but he left it a word as a wonder we
should raise it but he left he never
made it happen he'll ever did that and
later people started to
have a debate whether we should have
hard fork whether we should have a
hygienic size and if
uh the nitro box size will lead to
decentralization or not
and uh
uh whether we need to run uh the bitcoin
node on a raspberry pi or not
it's i think those uh lots of debate is
getting more and more uh bizarre and
more and more unrealistic um and uh um
first i started to take a
stance that we should increase the block
size and
obviously such kind of
debate was
what was not able to happen on lots of
them traditionally important discussion
values like bitcoin uh talk to r or rb
corn
it was kind of a sensor there uh and um
some of us believe that this uh if the
block size uh cannot or could not be
increased it may mean the uh defeat or
failure of bitcoin
so
widely uh
supported by lots of users so
even though
uh we may not get to uh the support from
the bitcoin core developers
i think it's better to have a kind of a
branch or a kind of um
different branch different ways we need
to reserve kind of a seed for the
bitcoins original uh design
so when you think about uh bitcoin and
that scaling uh debate right obviously
uh we get the fork we get bitcoin
bitcoin cash um there's a whole bunch of
questions that people want me to ask uh
i'm not gonna get to all of them but
maybe i'll ask you kind of two or three
of the the top ones that do our best to
kind of cover what people want to know
so first is um in terms of your personal
portfolio do you still hold bitcoin and
bitcoin cash do you hold other assets
like how do you think of your personal
portfolio uh and really kind of using
that as a proxy for um you know kind of
how you want exposure moving forward
yeah i held a lot of
different kinds of costs uh in very
early days i kind of was a i think just
you know born of a live porn just a few
days i started to mind my phone you know
that but
so i know problems that you have only
bitcoin i it's just anything other
podcast but i'm kind of very different
person
than you says i hold a lot of coins i
my portfolio i have like 20 to 30 kinds
of coins uh but the majority of them are
kind of ethereum bitcoin bitcoin cash um
and there is still some kind of kind of
litecoin um and uh xcc
right um
uh ecash basically it was a kind of four
cup [ __ ] of fork of bitcoin
and um
uh there are lots of other cons like a
lot of uh defy tokens um
and some other uh blockchains uh like
sol
um
yeah i heard lots of it yeah and between
bitcoin and bitcoin cash do you think
that you hold more bitcoin or more
bitcoin cash now
um
um
more bitcoin cash more bitcoin cash all
right uh and then when you think about
uh kind of where we are today in
hindsight knowing everything you know
now uh in terms of how the block size
debate worked out uh prices of assets
etc what do you think like the biggest
one or two lessons are that you learned
uh you know through that time period up
until today you mentioned earlier that
like there was this really uh
interesting thing where you went from a
student to a billionaire in like a short
period of time like like just what were
some of those lessons
yeah first i think i have started to
uh got some uh very very deep
understanding about the network effect i
learned about network effect quite uh
early but you know it was getting a
paper knowledge
but uh when you um go to uh
such kind of experience you know that
the level of
liberty effect is really strong it's
really something and
also i know that it's really hard to
reach kind of a
good governance or kind of governance or
consensus uh in a purely um crowd
or decentralized crowd i think that it
would be really hard uh
um and the people is very easy for
people to have a kind of
um
disagreement that cannot be consolidated
or be um
reach kind of agreement upon
with each other so um
i think
if i know the philosophy of people they
have a different a great different
opinions uh with the bitcoin core
developers but what they are really
choosing to do is that let's just
go to ethereum let's start some other uh
blockchain protocols and they are doing
quite fine doing quite well yeah i i
think uh maybe um in the future i think
i should take this the same
decisions as those people are doing
yeah and then in terms of um what i'll
call the like social aspect so there's
definitely a technical aspect to this
whole thing right in terms of uh do we
increase the block size do we not uh but
then there was an entire like i don't
know like social civil war within
bitcoin right it's probably the best way
to describe it um
and i feel like you and a couple of
other folks uh both on the bitcoin cash
side and on the bitcoin side really
really went at it and kind of uh uh
we're in this like deep debate and an
argument
is that something that you think is
healthy and like it had to happen in
order for us to get the technical side
worked out or do you feel like um that's
just something that like is a one-time
event and we're unlikely to see
something that uh kind of serious and
and aggressive in the future
yeah i think uh honestly speaking i
think it was really
bad
i think in kind of a confliction like
this
the first things to die is the truth
right and the second thing uh to dying
is uh
um it's kind of uh rational uh people
starts getting very emotional and um i
think both sides have a
line to each other
i have to admit that i think it's better
that the the two community uh separated
and the next kind of uh very meaningless
and a very destructive
debate with with each other i think
bitcoin uh are doing quite good are
doing pretty well these days it's a
stock value but um
this position is very strong and we see
lots of institutions are coming to this
and um
no matter what other coins they are
buying
but they are always buying bitcoin uh
and i see bitcoin cash even though it's
in a lot of very strong position right
now because uh
it did not get the name of bitcoin which
was very important
and
right now the market cap is
lagging behind um but we see that
bitcoin cash people are perish
extreme
of peer-to-peer extra cash and trying to
deal fairly
uh various kinds of infrastructure uh
that um uh waiting for people to use um
and i see that those in structures are
building from zero from uh to one and
two or even more and right now there are
kind of evm compatible
side chains on the bitcoin cash so i
think both
communities are more focusing on the
constructive work to do and to promote
and to grow its own community um i
believe that that's uh it's kind of a um
good situation uh
but right now i still see that uh some
of the
other community members are kind of uh
hate with each other but i guess it's
much much better than before that many
years ago
for sure
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're going to be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]